this is Cebu and I am on Jake they're
switching things are switching things
I'm doing an intro because I thought
it'd be nice it's for viewers to like
get an introduction or a second
this never happens in the history of
Jake oh wow they're making history right
now do they just flip the script on his
[ __ ] try again okay
[Music]
this is SEMA when you're watching JK
news unintentional time-traveling news
submitted by Greg with a peg Oh a mother
finally emerged from a coma after nearly
30 years
I should attach Pavel I wanted a [ __ ]
time-travel switch feel the different
vibes in the air different energy
different she woke up from a
time-traveling experience and she had a
coma no you wish time traveled 30 years
into the future
what I wish what happened was she
actually time traveled and in which she
came back she got into a coma
why did she want to be in a coma the
freak accident like you got into an
accident like that but if she went in a
time travel machine and when she came
back she went into a coma why would
people report it though nobody believes
that that even exists I know but I want
to believe that it's real goddammit
okay so this woman she was in the
backseat with her son her brother-in-law
was driving and they were going home
after picking her son up from school who
was four years old that's when they
collided with the school bus and she
like protected her son foolish he was
only able to escape but that was just
only a bruise pretty bad okay dead she
went into a coma and she's been in that
coma for the last 30 or 27 years if you
saw school bus coming hit you how would
you protect Isaac call her the same way
I'd probably like try to use my body as
this why because what do you want me to
do I want you to stay alive how do I
protect him by saying a lot you know
what I would do I would use that
three-year-olds text tech tech seeks
techniques and put the soft parts out
we'll take the kid like this if I was a
lady I would take my kid bend them over
like this and then a stick up this way
and my titties out that works out I
could save my kids are you put your kids
face on your cleavage right here no no I
turn sideways what is that but they're
not my titties out ass out on my cushion
okay big ass Tina you know what I just
pictured you know how everybody has car
cameras and [ __ ] I just picture him as a
mom and they're doing everything in
slo-mo the [ __ ] is lady doing or
anything is just like because like the
cop has to figure out how both of them
died it's the dumbest way to die ever
and I pictured my camera where the bus
is coming and I opened the door and I
leave my kid and I'm jumping out so
awkward and the kid survived what do you
say what was your [ __ ] dream line
it's too late do you see my [ __ ] lip
this global awkward conversation with
the kid happen if we both live I hope
you were driving the best way to protect
yourself is to turn around and have your
ass actually ought to something he
actually does it and he lives and you
guys are laughing it when he was the guy
that assumed that when a car was gonna
t-boned him he should drive his shoulder
into the wall my butt into this yeah
yeah yeah
you would have crack your [ __ ]
vertebrae do exactly what I want just to
like be you for a day no you don't your
minds no I think all of you guys me your
minds all work and very hilarious normal
one in the group to be honest with you
the [ __ ] normal yes you just said
you're gonna roll out of a [ __ ]
moving car and then if you and your son
both survive here it's gonna be an
awkward conversation yeah these are
facts gyah what would you do to save my
son yeah you see a school bus coming
towards your car what do you do I mean
the normal thing you just try to hug
them like what this lady did not me
you're not trying to survive I don't
know I'm just a sophomore coin yes
you could always make more babies the
baby can't make a baby
the baby can't make a baby because the
baby's gonna grow up what are you
talking about you proposed to have a
baby we protect you you all right this
plomo cam is this the bus is coming he
unhooks the seatbelt of his kid it hides
behind it because babies are softer they
don't break easily and they're like good
pillows boom
best parent on the earth well we all
have different parenting styles Joe I
don't even have a baby gonna [ __ ]
weasel dude that's a weasel move it even
David we got it because the kids will be
crying if the kid sees a school but he's
gonna hold on today I don't want to
Chuck traumatize the kid see I'm not a
bad person I'm just leaving my kid I'm
not hurting the kid David just goes out
the window trolls I've been practicing
this park tower and if he survives he
survives is what it is so what did what
happened when she woke up okay well
first let me tell you that she was 32 at
that time oh [ __ ] she woke up being 60 -
yeah her son is 32 now she is the same
age that she was when she went in his
coma yeah so the entire time he has
obviously never given up hope that she
was gonna wake up one day and so she
they would go to different hospitals and
somehow print Abu Dhabi oh I thought you
made prints like the artist prints the
one that passed away yeah so they were
able to get a grant up grunting the
crown prince court back in 2017 and so
with that grant they were able to move
her to a like a better hospital in
Germany so that's where she woke up to
Germans have a [ __ ] they have the
medicine down yeah how come this [ __ ]
Prince gives a [ __ ] about did it happen
in his country yeah Oh makes this happen
in the Abu Dhabi okay make sense this I
thought it happened out here and like I
don't know where they just like
he's right very generous baby shoes when
I think about Abu Dhabi princes is like
some guy in some traditional Middle
Eastern close with stunner shades just
doing doughnuts on the sand in the Lambo
yeah they usually have a hot - yeah like
why the [ __ ] is this philemon care about
and then in the back there's salt Bay
pouring cheese on a hamburger yeah yeah
so the mom their name is Amira woman in
a wheelchair it's a mind trick yes you
flipped it and as it's turning you know
how your mind's trying to make sense of
the image you see a gorilla face it's so
far away don't see is that a robe is
that a blanket I could not see what you
were looking at all I thought was a big
bait steve-o hit is at the science why
is it because our minds trying to do
something normal normalcy bias right
normalcy
all I saw was a no man babe sign I got
nothing yo what the [ __ ] is your minds
trying to make sense of what it doesn't
understand so like anything it could
recognize it was all the blacks were
crushed yeah so you just see a blood
that's why I didn't I didn't see that it
was for wheelchair she woke up I saw a
beautiful success story that is
beautiful every one's going on amazing
so she woke up and in she was like she
looked up and she immediately the first
thing she said was her son's names oh so
then she had been there this entire time
I it sounds like from the way he's
telling a story that he pretty much live
there
because he said like he woke up to her
calling oh my god yeah it's gonna make
me cry
30 years huh I'm hungry if I'm in a coma
guys just take me the [ __ ] out in the
first month bro you're not even making
it to a month dude it's the first hour
Gio's like he asked for this this is
what he wanted but why do you have
scissors just unplug it
[ __ ] don't [ __ ] polish oh he's
talking in his sleep it's just past
releasing well yeah so before she woke
up he said he got into this argument
with some hospital staff and that she
was making these noises and stuff and so
he called doctors over to check on her
and they were like oh no that's normal
but then like a few hours later is when
he woke up to her calling Dan that's all
[ __ ] beautiful so he was in a coma -
no oh it was just too and then she woke
up and then she's an Omani then he goes
I'm I wake up - so work together for 30
years she just barely sleeping like how
do they keep your muscles mono that she
she underwent a lot of physiotherapy to
prevent her muscles from deteriorating
do carry it's like crazy and how do you
stay fat for 30 years was fat she's fat
no she's not she's just in this she just
has a bunch of wheelchair with all her
why are you fat shaming Joe she looked
fat okay that's a legitimate question
and Plus this she has been awake for a
while there's a she here she's in a lot
of blankets okay okay if someone was fat
that is a question that is a serious
question but that doesn't happen because
they're usually skinny right well
because they're not eating solids that
yeah it's just IV and [ __ ] yeah no
muscle man there's no fat people in a
coma Joe I know that's what I'm saying
but it looked like she was so I'm just
only if there are fat people in the coma
that's what I'm I could put you in a
coma of real quick is that is that like
oh yeah really
I can't even punched me when I asked you
to punch me true I [ __ ] love you too
much [ __ ] heart of gold did ah is it
possible for there to be a fat person a
coma if they put pretty songs on IV
maybe you mean like for them to get fat
alright well maybe like I just picked
you the two going in their mouths and
that person is still in the tendency to
be fat and you start sucking on it yeah
I'm wondering it's like everyone kind of
loses weight I'm sure no you're only on
liquids for sure but they exercise your
body so they move your body like this
while you're sleeping
you've touched the arm of a girl who has
never moved once in their life and it
just feels like a sack of jello it's
just like bone and you can feel the bone
through their arms
crazy who's I've um yeah wherewhere did
you feel that I'm not gonna say we will
not say there's ladies out there that
feel like water below you've never
touched her not Matt who were like we
just they're just skinny fat yeah
because you carry the child in your arms
for so many years you're pretty good to
go
i tom Aegina huh no but there's somebody
who have you felt that thing at the toy
store remember well it's like it's like
a tube and then they usually have like
little like fake plastic goldfish in it
and then if you put lotion you could
probably [ __ ] it all those kids keeps
rolling out disappointed in myself
because it took for him to describe like
that to know what he's talking about
because i don't know what he was saying
that he goes dildo for a kid I was like
weird ass American it's a never getting
uncircumcised penis yeah it's like the
Chinese like it's a bag filled with like
liquid and you could just shake it and
it just feels funny you never see much
yeah yes and I'll just keep like I can
visualize what I've never seen it before
yeah give it a sip lock bag like chicken
thighs yeah yeah I understand that okay
I understand so if that's what that's
what this person's arm feels like god
yeah okay I know this is a beautiful
story and I'm really happy that yeah I
feel so bad I thought she was a girl was
she one of those comas that where she
can like hear people talking around her
over the time that's beautiful
so the point where she could tell
doctors when she's in pain that's also
she was able to have a conversation with
Omar but she'll get out of the
conversation she's not interested like I
wonder if she remembers what she was
doing in her third year of coma or like
the dream world as she was how old is
she no that's inception well yeah 32
plus 27 what's that math 59 she looks
really young no stress no wrinkles oh
yeah and no she was just dreaming
[Music]
[Music]